what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and the
question we're gonna answer in this
video is well we're gonna cover the
origins and powers of lorna dana pilars
but one of the side answer is one of the
byproducts of this video is gonna be an
answer to the question is lorna dane the
daughter of magneto because i feel like
that's the question everybody wants to
know is it true in the comics so I mean
I've been watching gifted I'm on like
episode 1 the show is really good so far
it's kind of weird I feel like Lauren
and Andy like the von strucker kids I
feel like they're stand-ins for Andrea
and andreas von strucker who are
basically the the super twins from DC
like they had to hold hands and they
could fly and shoot energy beams they
were like Chris Claremont creations back
in like uncanny x-men 200 or something
like that I don't know if they are maybe
they'll introduce the actual von
strucker twins I don't know I don't know
why you would introduce a von strucker
twins well I don't know I mean it is
interesting it's kind of intriguing so
with regards to Polaris her whole story
about her being the daughter of magneto
is weird it's one of those crazy
scenarios so originally back when she
was introduced in x-men number 50 by
Arnold Drake she appeared in like three
stories or at least it was a three part
story and it basically teased the idea
that she was a daughter of magneto there
was this guy named mesmero who was kind
of a weird hokey villain for back then
and his idea was to gather all the
mutants together and find this kind of
mutant Messiah who would embody all the
traits of magneto and would lead them to
you know conquer the world all that kind
of good stuff
and Polaris was a person that he settled
on so the whole idea here was that
mesmero made the statement that Polaris
is the daughter of magneto the problem
with this was that the x-men weren't
really that popular back then and so
there wasn't really a whole lot of
interest in the team hence the reason
why the publication was more or less
just kind of shuffled or Alisa was
scuttled in like you know issue number
65 and then it was reprints for 27
issues or something like that going into
the relaunch of giant-size x-men number
one that's the first time we ever got
that indication now eventually magneto
showed up in that story I think it was
issue number 52 and then we found out
that version of magneto was a robot and
so the whole idea was like okay that's
kind of weird like you know do we get an
actual explanation for this well
eventually the x-men line of comics were
relaunched with giant-size x-men number
one the title was renamed to uncanny
x-men and it's more or less been that
way ever since but the whole idea is
that the character of Laura Dane being
the daughter of magneto was basically
kind of teased at and hinted to over the
course of something like 40 years we
were never given a definitive answer now
the closest that we ever got or at least
up until the definitive origin came with
x-men uh it was in the mid 90s I think
it was anyway it was in the aftermath of
Age of Apocalypse which was basically an
alternate reality where apocalypse had
managed to conquer the world and you
know or conquered North America a set of
sites in the world that was really about
it in the aftermath of that story
various characters from that alternate
reality managed to escape its
destruction which included like Nate
grey x-men as well as dark beast who was
an evil version of hain't McCoy he was
an evil version of beasts and this dark
version of beasts had basically analyzed
the genes of of Lorna Dane and compared
it to Magneto and said she's not the
daughter of magneto so then we had our
answer so we were like okay cool she's
not the actual daughter of magneto fast
forward up until x-men I'm sorry I think
it's that yeah x-men issue number maybe
it's uncanny x-men issue number 431 I
think it is by Chuck Austin and then we
were told yes lorna dana is the daughter
of magneto so we're like okay is she the
daughter or is she not the daughter so
we got conflicting answers over the
course of marvel's publication history
now the kind of confusion and everything
was was sort of dere but this was
basically reconciled back in 2012 with
x-factor 243 uh but basically it was a
story there was written by Peter David
and the whole idea behind this was that
it involved a mishmash of different
characters like longshot and Monet st.
croix who had psychic powers and so on
and so forth but longshots ability or at
least as modified abilities and new kind
of powers that he had was that he could
touch an object and basically kind of
pick up psychic residue on it and what
had happened was Lorna Dayne had shown
him a picture that she kept for herself
where she had um the she basically said
you know look this is apparent by
picture that my parents had you know
back when I was younger and so on and so
forth and you know I've held onto it
ever since long shot touched it and got
this psychic feedback and so the whole
idea was the story that Lorna Dane had
pitched was that she didn't really know
what happened to her parents all she'd
known is that her parents were pilots
and the plane exploded in the the metal
was basically magnetized and the
indication was that magneto killed her
parents and so that was kind of the idea
you know going forward for a little
while was his story what we end up
finding out is that by virtue of Monet's
sake Roy basically linking the minds of
Lorna Dayne and longshot together that
yes magneto was present but the reason
why was because of the fact that Lorna
Danes biological mom had had an affair
with magneto and so ultimately Lorna
Dayne is the daughter of magneto the
problem with this was that Lorna Dayne
killed her parents
that's not funny we shouldn't laugh at
that but she had basically killed her
parents the whole
as she was a baby at the time while her
parents were flying a plane I think they
were going to Vegas or something like
that and they started arguing with one
another over the fact that Lorna Danes
biological mom had cheated on her
biological dad and so the result of this
is that while they were bickering and
arguing with each other Lorna Dane woke
up as a little baby instead of crying
panicking and freaked out and screamed
stop fighting and that are maddening
magnetic powers manifested and she
basically destroyed the plane the result
was that when she crash-landed we ended
up having Magneto and mastermind who
responded now mastermind of course is a
character that we haven't really talked
about too much ironically enough is the
first video I ever did on my channel and
so we have really talked about him a
whole lot since then
mastermind is a mutant his name is jason
wyngarde he's a mutant that has the
ability to cast illusions on he can
basically trick people into seeing
things that aren't there essentially he
controls the five senses so if you see
it smell it touch it taste it hear it or
you know feel it he can manipulate those
five things and make you believe that
whatever it is that he is creating an
illusion of is real so like in the case
of the Phoenix saga maybe was a Dark
Phoenix saga I think it led into the
Dark Phoenix saga when the Hellfire Club
took Jean Grey when she was the Phoenix
force but regardless jason wyngarde used
his powers which were amplified by Emma
Frost and essentially tricked Jean Grey
into believing that she was on like this
old pirate ship or something on those
lines she was you know this old colonial
chick or something which I guess she
dogged but she could smell assault on
the air she could feel the water like
hitting her face she thought it was 100%
real which is crazy but what ended up
happening is magneto instructed
mastermind who at the time was part of
the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants to
create an illusion in the mind of Lorna
Dayne basically tricking her into
believing the origin she previously had
was the real one but the fact remains to
answer the question yes Lorna Dayne is
the biological daughter of magneto that
was confirmed back in 2012 and has been
that way ever since with regards to
Lorna Dean versus Magneto that's the
question that a lot of people want to
know how powerful is Lorna Dean in
comparison to Magneto okay what we have
to do is we have to understand the
difference between powers and like the
ability to use powers just because
characters have the same power doesn't
mean they're equal in power like magneto
can control magnetism and Lorna Dane can
control magnetism the difference is that
magneto has a lot more experience with
his magnetic powers that Lorne a Dame
does now there was a point where she had
mental blocks in place and really that
was kind of like a story that came in
later on where they kind of introduced
that idea
by and large she's never been a equal to
magneto in power she's been exceedingly
close but she's never really been the
equal to Magneto and power there was a
story that was published in 2001 by
Grant Morrison called ia's for
extinction and he is for extinction
dealt with the idea of Cassandra Nova
who was this weird story where she was
basically a twin of Charles Xavier
that died in the womb like Charles
Xavier killed herself along those lines
it was it's really crazy and it's really
strange but essentially Cassandra Nova
had basically had these wild sentinels
rebuilt and then sent them to the mutant
island of Genosha and then wiped out 16
million mutants and Lorna Dayne was
there she was training with magneto at
the time for like six months or
something like that and she just
suffered like this catastrophic mental
breakdown that basically drove her
insane but a byproduct of being driven
insane is that these mental blocks that
kept her powers in check were removed
and her power was just kind of pushed to
the extreme of what it was capable of at
the time it doesn't mean it was pushed
to the absolute extreme the greatest
she'll ever achieved it just means it
was pushed to the extreme relative to
where she was at that point in time she
wasn't on par with Magneto Magneto's
more of like an omega-level threat even
though it's never been confirmed but we
all know it's true she's close but she
just doesn't have the nuances she
doesn't have the ability to manipulate
things in the same scale he does she can
manipulate the electromagnetic spectrum
to a degree she's not one of those who
can like traverse earth go to a
different planet and be just as much of
a threat there as she is you know with
regards to you know the planet Earth I
mean maybe she was during the
starjammers arc when she joined the
starjammers team during like war of
Kings doing war of keys maybe she was
because I member she fought Vulcan and I
think maybe she was she was a trans
level threat or a transplant threat I
don't know uh in any event the long and
short of it is that Marvel's never given
us a story where it's been like magneto
versus Polaris and so they've never
definitively stated who is more powerful
at the end of the day it really just
kind of boils down to who's a fan of
which magneto fans will say well of
course Maggie knows more probably more
powerful than she is and Polaris fans
will say no no Polaris is just as
powerful as Magneto there's no
definitive answer there and so it comes
down to power scaling where people just
kind of make stuff up and so again
that's kind of the weird thing there and
you know the kind of strange scenario we
don't have an answer yet hopefully we
get one sometime soon I mean the closest
that we ever get to an answer I think is
during the collapse of the multiverse in
secret Wars and there is an x-men tyent
I want to say is though it's one of the
last day
tions but it is it's a tie-in to the
events of secret Wars when the ultimate
universe and the main Marvel Universe
are about to crash into each other and
destroy what's left of the universes and
magneto travels to the ultimate universe
and unleashes holy hell unlike the
Sentinels who were there and Polaris is
just like my god I can't believe he's
that powerful that's the closest that we
get so I guess using that you can kind
of infer that he's more powerful than
she is but at the end of the day all
we're really doing is just guessing is
haphazard guessing and speculation and
that's all that ever really comes down
to so again no definitive answers there
but in terms of her being the daughter
of magneto that is true with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explained make sure you guys to the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and it will catch
you all later peace
[Music]